hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're gonna be doing
something different we're gonna be on
conquerors blade Thank You conquerors
blade of course for sponsoring today's
video and today they gave me a little
access of the game and I decided I
wanted to do a review of the game what's
been happening it's been out for a
couple of years and I wanted to see how
much the game is improved and what
you're currently looking at if you
wanted to hop into the game at 2020 and
just remember that even though this
video is sponsored so of course once
again thank you to them that doesn't
mean that I can't be critical and I will
be critical if I need to be in this
review so just keep that in mind so for
a quick brief summary of what conker is
blade is it's a free-to-play MMO kind of
realtime strategy game this may sound
like a mouthful don't worry we'll get
into all those explanations and where
those elements come in so don't worry
well the first thing you're gonna be
doing when you hop into the game is
customizing your character it has a very
nice diverse variety of options to pick
from like hairstyles tattoos scars etc a
bunch of different options for you to
pick to make your character unique from
others game also comes with a bunch of
weapons including the long sword and
shield the musketeer pull axe no dachi
longbow and short bow the short sword
and shield the spear and shield the
glaive and the dual blades so there's
tons of different options if you want to
pick stuff personally for me I'm a dual
blades person I like to be very up and
close but if you want to do range you
can use musketeer or the longbow or
short bow or if you don't like long
range in that sense and you'd like to
get up and close with people but have a
long weapon of course the glaive and the
no dachi and the pole axe work perfectly
for that as well each weapon in the game
has roughly 4 skills that you can equip
in battle and use as an upgrade system
as well to upgrade those skills maybe
increase in cooldowns or other things
like that very small my new changes or
upgrading the whole thing in general
bringing it to a tier 2 version this can
help you diversify your loadout and
really make sure that you know what
you're doing ahead of time and kind of
men maxing that build so you know
exactly how to defeat the enemy that
you're gonna be fighting the one thing
though is that there is so many weapons
so can be very hard to choose luckily in
the very first like 10 minutes of the
game you can have a tutorial where you
can spar with one of the Knights in the
area and you can test out all the
weapons on him but also if you don't
feel like going through all of that
trouble there is a statute that shows up
whenever you highlight the weapons that
can go from range difficult
the damage mobility defense and power
for example the dual blades excel in
power mobility and difficulty but they
do lack in reach defense and a little
bit of damage so if you don't feel like
actually testing out the weapons from
there you can use that as a simple guide
the story mode for this game has lots of
simple quests and even tutorials up
until level 16 so it may kind of seem
like a giant tutorial and it really is
in my opinion I feel like the majority
of this game is really based around the
PvP content whereas with the PvE side
like this it's really taking you through
those tutorials and making you learn all
the different necessities you're gonna
be learning through the rest of the game
and all those skills that you will be
using of course the higher you go up in
the levels the game has many different
battle modes and the story is going to
take you all those while showing youth
tutorials on what to do for those
specific modes for the simplest rundown
you have the troop training which is
going to be the very first thing you
learn because it's going to be the
necessity and it's going to be used in
every single game mode that you play
this is gonna teach you how to enter
certain fights with your troops how to
tell them to come towards you how to
defend how to attack what different
units are how they fare against other
units what formations you want them to
be placed down in and other things like
that to help you succeed the troops of
themselves also have a unit tree to
upgrade them for more damage and more
skills as well which is really cool so
lots of diversity in those specific
units I was going up against guys whose
minions and troops were on horseback so
that can definitely be a problem if I
was going up against those guys luckily
they were on my team the other trainings
also consist of siege attack training
and siege defense training while also
understanding how to use some of the new
mechanics within the battle like the
troop selection basically you can walk
up in the middle of a PvP game and go to
the troop section and swap out troops as
you need to let's say maybe that this
isn't the correct way maybe you don't
want to be using archers in this
situation you want to be using some
short-range people you could swap out
but obviously they're not everywhere in
the map they're very close to your spawn
it does have that negative aspect of you
having to go back to base roughly to go
get your troops you can't just do it
wherever and you'd be just sitting there
for the whole game these trainings like
the siege attack and the siege defense
will become available to you as you
progress through the story and play the
different game modes you're first gonna
be able to play training camp and then
once you win a game in training camp you
go to field battle and before you play
field battle it teaches you some of the
mechanics like capping objectives and
then you go to siege battle and of
course before siege battle you learn
about the
attacking and defending and then you go
on to death match and then you continue
after that up into other high level
things like expeditions and territory
Wars some of the expeditions the minimum
is level 20 with the expedition 3 being
a minimum rank of level 60 so especially
at 62 my knowledge is the highest rank
that you can get to so lots of levels to
use and you can use those level ups to
either auto assign or pick yourself and
upgrade your abilities with doing more
damage having more health other stuff
like that to help you in your PvP
matches I chose auto assigned since I
wasn't really familiar with what I
wanted to do with my character but if
you know exactly how you want to play it
you can obviously pick it on your own
stats now we can finally get into the
multiplayer side and this is definitely
one of my favorite things about this
game it seems like it is the main core
of the game and it's obviously really
well done and is definitely my favorite
what you do as soon as you start the
game as you pick the weapon you want
then you pick your equipment like siege
weapons and then you also select your
troops that you want to follow with you
into battle like I said before you can
swap these out whenever you want or when
that unit dies you can pick up a new
unit but this is for when you want to
pick the very first one you want to drop
with I usually end up picking the
pikemen as my very first choice because
for at least to me these things are
absolutely busted you want to fight
these minions in these troops like you
would if you're playing a MOBA obviously
if you're playing MOBAs like League of
Legends and smite you don't want to go
up against a group of minions when
you're on your own you want to have your
own minions fight them and you kind of
dish damage in the background while
avoiding hits this is kind of the same
premise you don't want to fight an
entire group of troops they will
absolutely melt you as they're seeing on
screen I killed like three or four guys
just using the pikemen because these
guys decided to pick archers even if
they had melee attack troopers they were
too far back and they didn't catch up to
him leaving them completely vulnerable
and they were melted in a couple seconds
now personally I didn't get a chance to
use every single weapon in every single
skill within those weapons that would
just take way too long to do and it
would take a hell of a lot of grinding
and time that I don't have to do so but
I know at least for the dual blades that
have some sort of smoke bomb you can
throw on to the ground and it
incapacitate the opponent for a little
bit and if you could find one of those
abilities to use on any of those weapons
that will help tremendously I know one
of the boys has like a kick that does
the same thing it leaves the opponent
knocked back for a couple seconds and
then you can end up using combos and
then like
said prepare that what the pikemen
you're gonna be destroying these guys in
one to two seconds if you're sick of
doing PvP battles and want to have some
kind of meaning to your fights of course
you can always do territory Wars you can
do that by joining a house and/or
Alliance and you can join up with those
do a bunch of territory Wars fight for
your Alliance and claim different areas
on the map which is always really cool
currently right now there is two things
going on there is season two which
dropped I think about a month or two ago
and they have a brand new unit called
the son of steps which is inspired by
the Mongolian warrior so if you end up
getting to that point you can use them
there's also a new battle pass with a
set of new challenges you could score
some season exclusive nomadic themes as
well as three new battlefields are gonna
be available to play and then the new
season also introduces more content
improvements matchmaking features UI
changes more NPC houses a new ranking
system player titles and a load more the
second thing that also went live at the
time that I'm making this at is actually
live right now on January 23rd is
actually the Lunar New Year it has a
bunch of different things going on right
now with different cosmetics and items
that you can pick up throughout the next
couple weeks so this is definitely a
perfect time to hop into the game and
get those rewards overall I gotta say
though this is definitely a really fun
game a lot better than I was expecting
it to be has some really nice unique
elements that I've never really seen in
a lot of games before and all of those
elements the MMO side with the PvE in
the PvP content and that real-time
strategy they all kind of meshed
together and flow really well into this
really cool multiplayer game one thing I
noticed though when playing PvP some of
the guys that were extremely high
leveled were actually kicking my ass
because of their really good minions so
to help you guys out you can click the
link down in the description to get a
bunch of different troops that I didn't
have access to but then you can have
access to so you don't have to have this
problem that I did and you can breeze
through the competition as always thank
you to conquerors blade for sponsoring
today's video but with that guys like
the video if you do enjoy subscriber for
you click the link down in the
description and in the comments for all
the juicy stuff on how to download
conquers blade and everything with it
and take care guys I'll see you in the
next video peace out
[Music]